[Musique]
restez dans votre voiture d'ogm ou
remady manette vous êtes passagère 5
étoiles selon les critères on va boire
un verre on restera une heure ou deux
régions
ce serait avec murray c'est quoi ton
numéro paix si j'ai pas trop où je veux
aller là tu te dis tu viens me faire
plaquer désolé de l'apprendre
y'a pas moyen qu'elle ferme sa grande
gueule des quotas de jeu doit être
quelque part dans une heure environ
avant toi j'ai déposé une fille demande
lui sied de nous accompagner à une
soirée de tincques à malibu j accepte je
serai ton chauffeur donc où est ce que
tu dis que cette fête a lieu déjà
était une cliente et maintenant on est
tous amis c'est vraiment adorable
je paye les bouteilles mais je vais
avoir besoin d'un peu de cash sa tempête
d'hier et pour moi je préférais trigger
[Musique]
a déjà vu ce qu'un magnum 44 de fer au
visage d'une femme salle fait
littéralement exploser des mois vous
appelez la police buts et avec moi je
peux savoir que vous jouez par un [ __ ]
de jeu mêlant veilleux j'étais en train
de rater
alethia cours d'aqua tu montes tu
voudrais pas rater la fin de ton propre
regard
je veuille venger la mort de mon père et
de ma mère je suis la porte humaine à
traquer capture
thivel c'est mon nom je m'appelle si vs
la chasse est finie grands là faut
survivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y arriverait plus vite s'ils ont
volé tous les deux espèrent que
j'abandonne pas vrai tellement bon
d'étendre mise elle sait comment voler
oui c'est comme si rien ne pouvait tenir
je pense qu'on pourrait essayer pas
porto voyage juste pour rire pourquoi
pas au boulot sans rire voilà ce que je
pense
on vole jusqu'à la ville on se prend un
repas chaud pendant qu'on s'informe sur
ces animaux qu'on est en train de
chasser
d'un autre côté on ne peut pas aller en
ville tout le monde déteste
toi tu mâche pas ses mots pourquoi tu as
abandonné le roi en fait non c'est de
l'histoire ancienne
pour ce qui est plus important c'est que
j'étais entendu parler de cette eau
amenant au fond lui donc des fleurs ça
fait toujours de l'effet avec les filles
ah ouais qu'est ce que t'en sais tu es
pas une fille selon ses dires je suis
une femelle et nous sommes très
sensibles à la beauté en génère
c'était pas le sujet si tu tiens à
éviter le sujet du roi
je comprendrais on a tous fait des
choses qu'on préférerait oublier
ce qui est important c'est ce qu'on fait
de notre vie
regarde autour de toi la vie est faite
pour être vécu
il faut poursuivre je crois que je
préférais quand tu étais un cheval et
quitte à voler tout seul
regarde ce qui nous attend de la forêt
tire encore trois lieux au moins c'est
le bon endroit pour trouver un loup
notre ami a beaucoup souffert là d'où il
vient
falloir en prendre soin c'est ce que
nous faisons de mieux ici ou de votre
belfast tu voudrais les saluer les
magnifiques
c'est la première fois qu'il réagit
comme ça avec quelqu'un tu dois avoir un
don
[Musique]
je serai de retour d'ici peu
veille sur lui pour moi d'accord tu te
tue vraiment de cet éléphant
ouais mon père est parti se battre
adam austin tadla qui je m'appelle tom
qu'est-ce qui se passe
le zoo est fermée aujourd'hui tu n'a
rien à faire ici aujourd'hui j'attends
vraiment content d'avoir fait
préliminaires
je me dois de suivre les ordres au cas
où les animaux s'échappe lors des
bombardements
vous approchez pas de poster je dois je
faire sortir
ce soir pour booster mais bien plus haut
que ce à quoi je m'attendais
madame austin et des mois c'est un
éléphant
les animaux de l'espagne rouzaud tout le
monde va se mettre à la recherche de
pasteur s'il le retrouve un jour
le tube
[Musique]
nous sommes à la recherche d'un
délitement
on va se faire tuer
on forme une équipe finissant ce qu'on a
commencé
quand cette fois j'ai participé à cette
aventure unique
[Musique]
je n'oublierai jamais
on sent moins seul
[Musique]
le même sens
et
des manifestants
[Musique]
c'est lui
m
[Musique]
blanc
ces frayeurs
non
[Musique]
il faisait
j'espère
ah ah ah progrès enregistrés sont forts
oh
pourquoi javaux ses yeux
[Musique]
frédéric doit être beaucoup plus
disciplinés comment vous voyez la suite
de sa scolarité
je ne vois pas du tout comment ils
pourraient entrer au collège avec ses
niveaux en fait votre méthode
d'enseignement qui est à revoir
tu ne vas pas avoir le choix il faudrait
juste que tu veux sans effort j'aurais
plus le temps de jouer
[Musique]
salut fredo je suis ton double et me
voilà à ton service
je suis parti
[Musique]
à partir de demain tu seras en
excellente écoliers tu veux aller à
l'école à ma place
sans être obligé bien sûr ce serait trop
génial
[Musique]
encore dix minutes est souvent je finis
déjà tout est correct
alors c'est lui qui va à l'école à ta
place tous les jours et il croit tout ce
que tu es devenu un intello du jour au
lendemain ou tu l'as trouvé
[Musique]
salut les loosers
ils sont vraiment dangereux il veut nous
voler nos vies
[Musique]
toute la classe a disparu dans nos
mairies
il est clair qu'un de nous deux est en
trop c'est chez moi ici pas chez toi
[Musique]
c'est l'ensemble de cette classe qui
soudainement devenu qu'il faut qu'on sur
notre glace
[Musique]
les rôles ce truc est déglingué de toute
façon
[Musique]